[Music]
now
valorent is a game that's evolving with
every month of passes
we see new teams rise rivalries boil
up and champions crowned they push the
very limits of what we think is possible
in this game by pulling off the most
incredible plays
some of those plays have happened so
recently that we felt it's about time to
update our rankings
so here are the top 10 best plays in
valorance history
kicking off our list at the number 10
spot is an incredible up play from cloud
nine's tens
they make their way on site no ten
everything tens with an ace tens has
built a bit of a reputation for himself
as one of ballarat's top aim gods so
when you put the op in his hands
you know you're about to see some magic
happen it'd be what it be my friend but
now
immortals after that last one are you
choking me
his tongue is really just pulled they
know they're collateral
at this point he's definitely mortals
what can they even do they make their
way on site
no
put c9 on his back that round
demolishing immortals with
pinpoint accuracy now that's how you
start a list
at number nine now we have wait
is that zywoo playing valor
your eyes do not deceive you that is
zywoo
hltv's number one ranked cs go player in
the world
popping off at underdogs november 2020.
the institute needed a sub for the event
and we can all agree that they brought
in a
hell
uh
esports look like an nacs team
ouch taking the number eight spot on our
list
is a big brain play from nip's crea to
win the match
korea's found four bringing it down to
just one it's all up the scream
in the one-on-two crea used a shrouded
step to teleport behind enemy lines
and right when he lines up his shot he
takes it
instantly taking out four members of
fish one two three
securing the round and game for ninjas
in pajamas
it's actually gonna be scream who takes
out rhyme as rhyme tried to get outside
the radius
of that detonation but couldn't quite do
it kriya
gonna go for report and yet again kriya
gets behind enemy lines
korea's found four i am speechless
when you get dunked on like that
that felt like shaquille o'neal taking a
five-year-old
and just smashing him in a one v one on
one like that was
disgusting
ready up your revolver because for our
number seven spot we're going to the
wild west with this thrifty from
shot up shot up has a good little
reposition a chance for two
and he's gonna land both headshots
looking one last
one up again with the sheriff three
kills on the sheriff
and that final shot wasn't more than
impressive that's the shot up that we
wanted to see that is the shot up that
everyone expects
that is what a hell of a performance
three
huge kills
coming in at number six is an absolute
classic
from swirl he might just get the eyes
are you serious
i've never seen anything like that one
stuck on c
defending the plant swells stood alone
against order
popping in and out of jet smoke to
single-handedly
decimate his opponents just sitting well
not disco sorry it's actually dick
stacey sitting inside of the dark arm
and the clown
somehow swirled winning that one
has to release oh and it catches the 12
hp tucks as well
in the smoke swirl is already done
enough here the cloud burst is denied
the other
world swells putting on a show and we've
all got tickets to it
he might just get a 4k here he might
just get the eyes
are you serious i've never seen anything
like that one
that's right he won the 1v4 with the
default pistol
maybe this gun is busted after all
hiko takes the halfway spot on our list
with a clutch that reminds us
of the good old days now over the years
hiko has developed a bit of a reputation
for being a clutchmeister and up against
the moon raccoons in overtime at the
first strike qualifiers
heco reminded everyone that he's still
got that young man clutch factor
and also dicey eco goes for double and
now it's all down to him this is gonna
have to be a quad kill for him to pull
things through and keep him alive
he's able to get the triple and he
doesn't know where the last player is
alexander he's creeping these guys
the rosies break around the rosies and
he's creeping out he
doesn't know he's got no intel at all oh
he's using the hundreds fury and that's
a good way to beat the time and he makes
no way clutch man
[Music]
taking the number four spot on our list
is a laser-like ace from subrosa
seven bullets that's all sub rosa needed
to put tsm
on his back and take the early lead
against immortals at the clg blitz cup
oh this is gonna be huge he's gonna spot
all of them right now
one two three four looking for the ace
right now and it's about to be peaked
out here
silva arrow to come out and he's going
to win this fight and he does
with another headshot seven bullets used
oh yeah
says we're not worthy subrosa has gone
from being an
nacs also ran to one of the most
exciting players in valorant
now if that's not a glow up i don't know
what is
rocket launching his way to the number
three spot is asana with this explosive
ray's ace
it used to be the rey's old multi kills
were a dime a dozen
but these days players are smart enough
to see it coming
they don't group up they don't let it
happen
the sky all it's coming out paranoid is
going to have to be wasted on this
oh no he's the triple off the rocket is
the fourth kill he's working on the ac
that's absolutely monstrous performance
there on short a
looking for the last player the triple
frag
this early into the round grand finals
and the ace
for arsenal which is why this insane
shot from asana during the valor and
first strike any finals
was just so crazy it took everyone by
surprise
for our runner-up spot we have the lone
terminator bjor
rampaging his way through tsm all by
himself
now tsm is one of the best teams in
ballarat right now
and trying to beat them can be a tough
feat for just about
any team but bjor did not care who he
was facing
he put built by gamers on his back and
plow through tsm
this is gonna be a mess the operator
misses the drone is trying to get some
damage in luckily
cutler's there to sort of build him up
but it's completely missed he gets free
he just snook fights this could be a
crazy ace
what the hell is bjorn doing
oh
that was the most insane ace bro what
taking the top spot on our list is an
incredible eco ace from the one and only
sinatra
oh my goodness and now the show stopper
to get it and
he got something oh my gosh
during the 30 bomb summer cup finals tsm
were looking to cement their lead on
split
and sentinels were on an eco things were
looking
easy for tsm that was until
sinatra showed up rodel actually stuck
in the back corner
so now the native the raise is gonna
land he's able to dash out but
is his position good enough no sinatra
gonna be taking him down with that
frenzy so
the b site isn't gonna be in possession
now for sentinels they pick up the
operator for sinatra
here's them did the same kind of ghost
hold in the tower
this time doesn't work out as it gets
punished by a full sight push
there's the fleet tank this is going to
be sinatra misses one but gets the
second that's a triple kill oh
four oh my goodness and now the show
stopper to get it and
he got something oh my gosh
sinatra fought off all five tsm players
defended the bomb and ended the round
with a perfectly timed alt from beyond
the grave
and he did it all on an eco round
alright those were the top 10 best plays
in ballarance history
and the game is still only about a year
or so old at this point quite a new game
but just before you guys go if you
haven't done so already make sure you
hit the subscribe button
we are on the road to 2 million
subscribers if you can believe it
and you can help us get there thanks for
watching guys and i'll see you all in
the next one
time to stay home stay safe and stay
home
that was very weird that was weird
that's really creepy that was there like
no other information on that call
i didn't think until now that the phrase
stay safe stay home
could be so creepy
[Music]
that's terrifying dude someone's going
to crawl through my phone and kill me in
my sleep
stacy stay home yeah i told you to stay
home dang